IT CERTAINLY IS POISED TO BE AN
EXTRAORDINARY TRIAL OVER DARCY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL YOUR
REPORTING ON THAT. RIGHT NOW. IN
THE SENATE, THE GLOVES ARE OFF.
YOU MADE MORE MISSTATEMENTS AND
A SHORTER PERIOD OF TIME THAT I
HAVE EVER HEARD. PLEASE CORRECT
ME IF I'M WORTH $8 MILLION.
EXCUSE ME PUBLIC EXCUSE ME. GO
AHEAD. ALRIGHT EXCUSE ME. YES,
SIR. MILLION DOLLARS. THAT'S
GOOD NEWS TO ME. I'M NOT AWARE
OF IT. THAT'S A LIE. ALL RIGHT
NUMBER TWO RECORDS. YOU'RE
PROBABLY LOOKING AT SOME PHONY
RIGHT WING INTO NET STUFF. IT
AIN'T TRUE. YOU SHOULD READ
BEYOND THAT. NOW THAT EXCHANGE
VERY HEATED BETWEEN SENATOR
BERNIE SANDERS AND REPUBLICAN
SENATOR MARK WAYNE MULLEN THAT
CAME DURING A HEARING ON
STARBUCKS ALLEGED UNION BUSTING
TACTICS. HOWARD SCHULTZ IS THE
STAR WITNESS TODAY, JUST DAYS
AFTER HE STEPPED DOWN FROM HIS
THIRD STINT AS THE CEO OF
STARBUCKS. HE IS THERE UNDER THE
THREAT OF SUBPOENA FROM BERNIE
SANDERS. CNN'S MADIGAN HAS BEEN
FOLLOWING ALL THIS MAT THAT
EXCHANGE THAT WASN'T EVEN THE
MAIN EVENT. IT WAS IT WAS, YOU
KNOW, THERE WAS FOUR SCHULTZ TO
TESTIFY. SO WHAT DID WE HEAR ON
THE STARBUCKS FRONT? THE MAIN
EVENT REALLY WAS BERNIE SANDERS
CONFRONTING STARBUCKS FOUNDER
HOWARD SCHULTZ ABOUT HIS
COMPANY'S ALLEGED UNION BUSTING
SANDERS DIDN'T MINCE ANY WORDS.
HE ACCUSED STARBUCKS OF WAGING
QUOTE THE MOST AGGRESSIVE AND
ILLEGAL UNION BUSTING CAMPAIGN
IN MODERN HISTORY. AND HE NOTED
THAT SCHULTZ, THE COMPANY'S
FOUNDER, ONLY AGREED TO TESTIFY
AFTER BEING THREATENED WITH A
SUBPOENA. LISTEN TO THIS
EXCHANGE BETWEEN BERNIE SANDERS
AND THE STARBUCKS FOUNDER. LET
ME REMIND YOU THAT FEDERAL LAW
18 U. S CODE SECTION 1001
PROHIBITS. KNOWINGLY AND
WILLFULLY MAKING ANY FRAUDULENT
STATEMENT. I UNDERSTAND THAT
WERE YOU EVER INFORMED OF OR
INVOLVED IN A DECISION? TO FIRE
A WORKER WHO WAS PART OF A UNION
ORGANIZING DRIVE. I WAS NOT WERE
YOU EVER INFORMED OF OR INVOLVED
IN A DECISION TO DISCIPLINE A
WORKER IN ANYWAY, WHO IS PART OF
A UNION ORGANIZING TRIFE? I WAS
NOT HAVE YOU EVER THREATENED,
COERCED OR INTIMIDATED A WORKER
FOR SUPPORTING A UNION? I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN INTERPRETED. YOU KNOW,
DIFFERENT WAY THAN I INTENDED.
TO MAKE HIS POINT. SANDERS
POINTED TO A RULING FROM JUST A
FEW WEEKS AGO BY A JUDGE AT THE
NATIONAL LABOR RELATIONS BOARD,
WHO FOUND THAT STARBUCKS
DISPLAYED QUOTE EGREGIOUS AND
WIDESPREAD MISCONDUCT IN ITS
DEALINGS WITH EMPLOYEES TRYING
TO UNION UNIONIZED IN BUFFALO,
NEW YORK NOW FOR HIS PART,
SCHULTZ, HE REPEATEDLY STRESSED
THAT STARBUCKS HAS NOT BROKEN
THE LAW. HE ALSO REFERRED TO
THESE ALLEGATIONS FROM THE LRB
AS JUST MIRROR ALLEGATIONS ONCE
THAT HE THINKS WILL BE DISPROVEN
OVER TIME. HERE'S WHY ALL OF
THIS MATTERS. I MEAN, STARBUCKS
, OF COURSE, IS A BRAND THAT A
LOT OF AMERICANS CARE ABOUT THEY
LOVE. IT'S ALSO A MAJOR
EMPLOYER. LOOK AT THAT. ALMOST
HALF A MILLION PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD WORK FOR STARBUCKS MORE
THAN A QUARTER OF A MILLION IN
THE US ALONE, STARBUCKS RAISED
ITS MINIMUM WAGE TO $15 AN HOUR
RECENTLY AND HOWARD SCHULTZ SAYS
THE AVERAGE STORE WAGE IS 17 50
NATIONALLY, BUT CLEARLY,
STARBUCKS HAS BECOME SORT OF THE
LATEST FLASHPOINT IN THIS
GROWING EFFORT AROUND THE
COUNTRY BY WORKERS WHO WERE
TRYING TO FIGHT FOR BETTE